Before we dive in, a quick heads up. If you're a qualified psychologist in private practice, then Dr Claire Plumley and I would love to invite you to our next in-person event. It's the psychologist Christmas Social, happening in Kingscross London on Saturday, the 6th of December 2025. It's your chance to connect with other brilliant minds, enjoy some festive food and feel part of a real community, especially if you're missing that work Christmas due feeling. Faces are limited and feeling fast, so if you or a colleague might be interested, you can find the link to grab your ticket in the show notes or in my bio on social media or just send me a DM. Dr. Claire and I will look forward to seeing you there.
在深入探讨之前，先给大家提个醒。如果您是一位拥有私人执业资格的心理学家，克莱尔·普拉姆利（Claire Plumley）博士和我诚挚邀请您参加我们的下一场线下活动。这是心理学家圣诞社交聚会，将于2025年12月6日星期六在伦敦国王十字区举行。这是一个与其他优秀头脑交流、享用节日美食并感受真正社区归属感的机会，特别是如果您因为这种感觉而错过了单位的圣诞聚会。名额有限且报名迅速，所以如果您或您的同事可能有兴趣，您可以在节目简介或我社交媒体的个人简介中找到获取门票的链接，或者直接给我发私信。克莱尔博士和我期待在那里见到您。
Water is so much more than just a way to keep our children and ourselves clean. It can be a powerful tool for bonding, calming the nervous system and laying the foundations for trust and confidence. Whether you're a parent looking to feel more confident with your newborn or a professional, curious about how sensory experiences shape attachment, this conversation is for you. I'm Dr. Marianne, a clinical psychologist and today I'm joined by Jo from Acrosensory, where we'll be exploring how water, from bath time to baby swimming, can nurture, connection and resilience. Like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist and I am joined here today by Joe Wilson. Welcome along, Joe.
水不仅仅是保持我们和孩子清洁的一种方式。它可以成为建立亲密关系、平静神经系统以及为信任和自信奠定基础的强大工具。无论您是想对新生儿感到更有自信的父母，还是对感官体验如何塑造依恋感到好奇的专业人士，这次对话都是为您准备的。我是玛丽安（Marian）博士，一名临床心理学家，今天和我一起的是来自Acrosensory的乔（Jo），我们将共同探讨水（从洗澡时间到婴儿游泳）如何能够培育连接与韧性。请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我一起的是乔·威尔逊（Joe Wilson）。欢迎你，乔。
Oh, thank you so much. Hi, everybody. So before we dive into who you are and all of that stuff, why is water such a powerful medium really for helping bonding with babies? I think sometimes we underestimate the power of water. actually. I think water just happens to be around and it's like a commodity really. But water is so meaningful. It can really, really teach us. At the end of the day, it's natural and it is so accessible. But for me, it's like pure presence. You know, like when you're so busy in the daytime, you've always got divided attention. But water, what it does, it demands our 100% attention. And that's the message that I always give to my parents as well, because you do have
哦，非常感谢。大家好！那么，在我们深入探讨你是谁以及所有这些事情之前，为什么水对于帮助建立婴儿的亲密关系来说真的是一种如此强大的媒介呢？有时候我们其实低估了水力量。我认为水只是恰好在身边，它真的就像一种日常必需品。但水是如此具有意义。它确实能够给我们上课。归根结底，它是自然的，而且非常容易获得。但对我来说，这就好比纯粹的当下。你知道，就像你在白天非常忙碌时，你的注意力总是分散的。但是水，它的作用是要求我们100%的注意力。这也是我总是传达给我所教的家长们的讯息，因为你确实
to be really respectful around water and you always have to supervise. So I have a little tagline that I always share with all my swim families, and I always say it's all about 100% attention, not divided attention. And that has a real powerful meaning for presence with a baby, but also you're in a medium, if you are in a swimming ball, that is very much skin to skin, or of course if you're in the bath as well, babies in the bath and they're really enjoying that activity. But it's an activity that you can be with your baby. So very much with your baby rather than doing things to your baby because there's lots of things out there that you have to do. But this is more of an activity that you can really, really enjoy together. Like, almost
在水边时必须非常尊重它，而且你必须时刻监督。所以我有一个自己一直在所有游泳家庭中分享的小标语，我总是说这完全关乎100%的注意力，而不是分散的注意力。这对于与婴儿共处当下有着非常强大的意义，而且，如果你在一个游泳池里，你是在一种非常肌肤相亲的媒介中，当然如果你在浴缸里也是如此，婴儿在浴缸里，他们真的在享受那个活动。但这是一种你可以陪伴婴儿的活动。更多的是陪伴你的婴儿，而不是对你的婴儿做这做那，因为外面有很多事情是你“必须”对他们做的。但这更多的是一项你们可以真正、真正一起享受的活动。就像，几乎
like mutual delight. Yeah, absolutely. And in a world where we're so switched on, where we often might have a phone in our hands, this is an opportunity to be screen-free. And I think really it's reminding me of some of the kind of infant-parent observation stuff that we might get in psychology, looking at the quality of that eye-gaze, looking at being attuned, really,
就像共同的愉悦。是的，绝对是这样的。在一个我们如此高度兴奋、手中经常拿着手机的世界里，这是一个远离屏幕的机会。我想这确实让我想起了一些我们在心理学中可能会接触到的婴儿与父母观察的内容，观察那种眼神交流的质量，观察真正的合拍，
and following your baby's lead. Could you tell us a little bit about how you see that unfold with babies and parents? Yeah, so when we are with, babies in water the nice thing is that a lot of the time we're down at their eye level as well and again you talked about eye contact us that's really lovely to really just follow their lead and sometimes babies you know they have to just have a sensory break they gaze away but they can come in but you're in a much closer contact situation with your baby and a lot of the time if you're in a swimming pool or
并跟随你婴儿的引导。你能跟我们聊聊你是如何看到这在婴儿和父母身上展现出来的吗？好的，所以当我们和婴儿一起在水里时，好的一大部分在于很多时候我们也是处于和他们平视的视线水平。同样，你刚才谈到了眼神接触，这真的非常可爱，能够真正地跟随他们的引导。有时候婴儿，你知道，他们只是需要一个感官休息，他们会把视线移开，但他们还会再看过来。不过你处于一种与婴儿更近的接触情境中，而且很多时候如果你在游泳池或
in the bath you've got beautiful skin to skin as well which is really really nice but what we're we're doing is we are really feeling into baby's cues and you know do they like their bath how are they feeling today are they a little bit fussy or are they really active and ready for their their bath so i think baby is really able to you know present how they're feeling as well and because as you say we have like less distractions we can pick up and we can really attune our our cues as well. Yeah, I remember, I think I was probably day three or day four when I had my first baby, who you got to know a little bit as well, and we'll talk about that shortly, but it was like the three-day sort of weep, really. I was so overcome. I'd had a section. I was
在浴缸里，你也有美妙的肌肤相亲，这也是非常非常棒的。但我们在做的是，我们真正去感受婴儿的暗示，你知道，他们喜欢自己的澡吗？他们今天感觉如何？他们有点挑剔，还是非常活跃并准备好洗澡了？所以我认为婴儿真的能够表现出他们的感受，而且正如你所说，因为我们正如你所说干扰较少，我们能够捕捉到并真正调整我们的暗示。是的，我记得，我想那大概是我生第一个宝宝的第三天或第四天，你对他也有一点了解，我们稍后会谈到这一点，但那真是一种类似“产后第三天情绪崩溃”的状态。我当时情绪激动极了。我做过剖腹产。我
still in loads of pain. My milk was all coming in, like, and I was sitting on the toilet, lid closed as my husband was running a bath for him, and I think it was probably his first bath. and I was just holding him, waiting for the, I think I was holding him naked because he's ready to get in the bath, ready for him to get in the water. I was just like crying and I was just like, I just love him. I just love him. But there's something about those very early days and those very early experiences and trying to get it right. I think he might even have been crying at the time. How do we, how do we begin to support those very early bus?
依然疼痛难忍。我的母乳开始下来了，当时我坐在盖着盖子的马桶上，我丈夫正在为他放洗浴水，我想这大概是他的第一次洗澡。我只是抱着他，等着……我想我当时光着身子抱着他，因为他准备好进澡盆了，准备好下水了。我当时就在哭，我只是觉得，我太爱他了。我太爱他了。但在那些非常早期的日子里，在那些最早的体验中并试图把事情做好，总有一些特别之处。我想当时他甚至还在哭。我们如何，我们如何开始支持那些最早的澡？
especially if they are crying and they're upset it's it's really difficult we've got all of these hormones going on we are sleep deprived you know if we're thinking about the very early days mine didn't sleep for like 20 months that that first one but it's just really hard joe how do we try and be mindful how do we try and be respectful of of that process it's going to be very different to what they're used to as well and i think what we've got to be remind is that every babies different. So there's a lot of babies that have a natural affinity to water and they find water really soothing and calming. So if you have got a fuzzy baby, perhaps, water is going to be the absolute perfect place that's going to really, really calm them down and it's going to really
特别是如果他们在哭泣和心烦意乱的时候，这真的很难，我们体内所有的荷尔蒙都在变化，我们睡眠不足。你知道，如果我们回想那些非常早期的日子，我的第一个孩子有20个月都不睡觉，那真的很难。乔，我们该如何努力保持正念？我们该如何努力尊重那个过程？这也会和他们习惯的非常不同。我想我们必须记住的是，每个婴儿都是不同的。有很多婴儿对水有着天生的亲和力，他们发现水非常抚慰和镇静。所以如果你有一个爱哭闹的婴儿，也许水将是绝对完美的场所，它真的、真的能让他们平静下来，并真正
soothe them. Particularly before bed, you can start a little routine. Of course, there are some babies that they have just that tiny little bit more extra stimulation and then that can actually just be too much. I think the important message for anybody really in parents and caregivers is that bath time doesn't actually have to be the same time of day. We're really tuning into when baby is ready. You know, a lot of the time we think about it has to be at the end of the day. But I would say, you know, when is good for you and when it's good for baby. And it's okay to make a few mistakes because baby is just, you know, always forgiving us for trying
安抚他们。特别是在睡觉前，你可以开始一个小小的常规。当然，也有一些婴儿，他们受到的刺激稍微多了一点点，那可能实际上就会变得太多了。我认为对任何人（无论是父母还是照顾者）来说，重要的信息是，洗澡时间其实不必在一天中的固定时间。我们要真正调整到婴儿准备好的时间。你知道，很多时候我们认为它必须在一天结束的时候。但我要说的是，什么时候对你合适，什么时候对婴儿合适，这才是最重要的。犯几个小错误也没关系，因为婴儿只是，你知道的，总是原谅我们的尝试，
and I think the important thing is, is just being together in that moment. Yeah, and I have to confess, I don't think I am the funnest of parents, Joe. I think I'm cuddly, I am nurturing. For whatever reason, maybe my own developmental experiences, I don't think I'm super fun. And so my husband always used to do way more fun baths than I did. How can we empower people to make bath time fun and nurturing? So I always sort of come back to almost like a little bit of a sensory five. So you have got your voice and babies love our sing-song voices.
而且我认为重要的事情，就是在那个时刻在一起。是的，我必须坦白，乔，我觉得自己可能不是最有趣的父母。我觉得我很抱歉，我很温柔，我能给予抚育。不管出于什么原因，也许是我自己的发展经历，我觉得自己并不是超级有趣。所以我的丈夫过去总是比我做更多有趣的澡。我们如何赋能人们，让洗澡时间变得有趣又充满滋养呢？所以我总是回归到某种类似感官“五件套”的东西。首先，你有你的声音，婴儿喜欢我们歌唱般的嗓音。
So we don't even have to like sing or do rhymes, but they just love when we talk to them, talking through the bath time as well, adding in simple words, a splash in and just making up things. baby loves that movement in the bath babies love to wriggle and of course on dry land they're quite fixed but in the bath there are so much more free movement and then we have got that beautiful eye contact as well that I was saying they really really love us when we're just watching and looking together and then adding in just a really simple bath toy so nothing too much
所以我们甚至不需要唱歌或念童谣，他们就是喜欢我们跟他们说话，一边洗澡一边用语言描述，加入简单的词汇，泼水，然后即兴发挥。婴儿喜欢那种在水里的移动，婴儿喜欢扭动，当然在陆地上他们的身体相当固定，但在浴缸里有更多的自由移动。然后我们还有我刚才说的那种美好的眼神接触，当我们只是在一旁观看、一起注视时，他们真的、真的非常喜欢我们这样做。接着还可以加入一个非常简单的洗浴玩具，不用太多，
It could be just some plastic balls or a simple cup. So really, really simple things for babies in the bar, definitely. One of my favourite things, and something I've still got, actually, was from a friend who'd had a baby, I think, around the same time as me. And she bought us a set of 10 stacking cups, and all of them had, like, slightly different holes in the bottom. So they all came out slightly differently. And we used those so much.
可能只是一些塑料球或者一个简单的杯子。所以对于在浴缸里的婴儿来说，是非常非常简单的东西，绝对是的。我最喜欢的东西之一，也是我至今仍然保留的东西，其实来自于一位朋友，她的孩子出生的时间跟我差不多。她给我们买了一套10个叠叠杯，所有的杯子底部都有稍微不同的洞。所以水流出来的方式都略有不同。我们经常使用这些杯子，
and we actually still use the big blue one in our bathroom to keep all our toothpastes in because, you know, they've been such a part of our story. It was really hard to let them go. But yeah, like you might just enjoy this. But I know if people are thinking about baby swimming as a rite of passage, and I would say I loved it. So I did it with you with my youngest, and I loved it.
而且我们现在实际上还在浴室里用那个最大的蓝色杯子来装所有的牙膏，因为，你知道，它们已经成为我们故事的一部分了。要放下它们真的很难。但是，是的，就像你可能会喜欢这个一样。但我知道如果人们把婴儿游泳视为一种成长仪式，而且我会说我很喜欢它。所以我和我最小的孩子一起跟你学过游泳，我太喜欢了。
It was such a special time. But I'm guessing you probably get parents that are actually scared of water or maybe aren't swimmers themselves. How do you encourage them to still think that maybe that's something they should do with their baby? So I always say start at home in the bath and I think there are just so many things that you can do for water acclimatization and I think that can, you know, just break barriers really of just knowing that your baby is comfortable in the water and, you know, go in to some lovely splashy moments and things like that and you think, oh actually, yeah, you know, let's try it. And I think the environment is really important. So going to a pool that you perhaps know and it's really familiar or just going and having a walk around before you can get into the pool and talking to the teacher if you're going to a class or just, you know, people around the pool if it's just an open session. And I would always say check the water temperature as well. I think some pools can be quite cold. So I'd say, you know, pick a nice warm pool, particularly if you are with your baby.
这是一段非常特别的时光。但我想你可能会遇到那些其实怕水或者本身不怎么会游泳的父母？你如何鼓励他们依然认为这可能是他们应该和婴儿一起做的事情呢？所以我总是说先在家里的浴缸开始，我认为有太多的事情你可以用来做防水适应，我认为这真的能打破内心的屏障，让你知道你的宝宝在水里是舒适的，然后，你知道的，去体验一些可爱的戏水时刻诸如此类的事情，你会想，哦，其实，是的，你知道的，让我们试试吧。我认为环境真的很重要。去一个你可能了解并且非常熟悉的游泳池，或者在进泳池前先去走走看看，如果你要参加课程就和老师聊聊，或者如果只是开放场次，就和泳池周围的人聊聊。我总是建议也要检查水温。我认为有些泳池可能会比较冷。所以我建议，选一个温暖舒适的泳池，特别是当你和宝宝在一起的时候。
And they just know the areas of the pool. So you don't have to. I think we not put a lot of pressure on ourselves. We have to swim. But no, going there, just holding baby, being together in the water and even walking around is absolutely fine. Yeah, it's hard, isn't it, when you've got a baby on a schedule as well? If it's like, you know, your swim lesson time is like usual nap time or lunchtime
而且他们只要熟悉泳池的区域就行了。所以你不必——我觉得我们不应该给自己施加太大的压力。我们必须去游泳。但不是的，去那里，只是抱着宝宝，一起在水里，甚至只是走动一下也完全可以。是的，当你还要让宝宝按时作息时，这真的很不容易，对吧？如果你的游泳课时间正好赶上宝宝通常的小睡时间或午餐时间，
or when you'd usually feed them. Like, I remember thinking, oh, what if he's going to be asleep? Or, you know, it's really hard to disrupt that. But I think we also need to think about actually, yeah, routine is essential. It's kind of good for our own sanity. My babies didn't get that memo. They didn't really do schedules. But it's still important.
或者你通常喂他们的时候。就像，我记得当时想，哦，如果他睡着了怎么办？或者，你知道的，要打乱这个规律真的很难。但我认为我们也需要考虑，其实，是的，规律是必不可少的。这对我们自己的理智也有好处。我的宝宝可没有收到那个备忘录。他们不太遵循时间表。但这依然很重要。
And I think for our own mental health as parents, it's still important that we're doing things together. Like, I really love baby massage. I really love baby swimming with you, because it's that reciprocal thing, but it's something it gets you out of the house as well. Otherwise, your life can become very insular. And I think even beginning to think that I can't go out by myself or I can't do this or, you know, like it really matters, isn't it? These activities, they're not just maternity or paternity leave rights of passage. We are creating and developing those very early attachment relationships that we hope will become long-term lovely relationships in future. Yeah, and it's a relationship that we
而且我认为为了我们作为父母自身的心理健康，我们一起做事情依然很重要。比如，我真的很喜欢婴儿按摩。我真的很喜欢和你一起带宝宝游泳，因为那是双向互动的，而且它能让你走出家门。否则，你的生活可能会变得非常孤立。而且我认为，甚至开始觉得我不能一个人出门，或者我不能做这个，或者，你知道的，这真的很重要，对吧？这些活动不仅仅是产假或陪产假的成长仪式。我们正在建立和发展那些早期的依恋关系，我们希望这些关系在未来能成为长久美好的关系。是的，这是一种关系，我们
are building with our baby, but also others as well. And I think, you know, we mustn't forget babies. Babies, we're all born social little humans and they love being with other babies as well. It's so nice in the pool, or if you've got people around the house as well, you know, when they just see him and it's just that surprise, isn't it? But I think. think in the water, I don't know if you've heard of the blue mind theory, that there's actually a lot of science and research that water has a way, a magic way, of actually releasing happy hormones in the brain. And people that are in water or around water are actually happier as well. So there's lots of research around the blue mind. So yeah, I think if we are a little bit
不仅是在和宝宝建立，也是在和其他人建立。而且我认为，你知道，我们不能忘记婴儿。婴儿，我们生来就是充满社交意愿的小人类，他们也很喜欢和其他宝宝在一起。在泳池里，或者如果你家里也有其他人，你知道，当他们看到对方时那样的惊喜，不是很美妙吗？但我认为。在水里，我不知道你有没有听说过“蓝色思维（Blue Mind）”理论，其实有很多科学和研究表明，水有一种神奇的方式，能够在大脑中释放快乐荷尔蒙。身处水中或水边的人实际上也会更快乐。所以有很多关于“蓝色思维”的研究。所以，是的，如果我们有点
low or a bit tired or yeah let's see if we can maybe run a bath or go to the pool i love that and it's making me think about people that live by the sea and regularly get in the water um they certainly let me seem pretty happy don't they and our bath broke a couple of years ago joe and the whole bathroom has needed fixing um and just tearing out and it's something we've never quite got around to but when we were on holiday in the summer we had a lovely bath and myself and my youngest would be using that bath daily, not together at this age, but daily. And I just thought, oh, I so love a bath. I'm probably a more bath person than a shower person. And it's really made me think, yeah, we do need to get this bathroom situation sorted because I need
情绪低落、有点疲惫，或者，是的，让我们看看能不能放一缸水或者去趟泳池。我太喜欢这个了，这让我想到了那些住在海边并经常下水的人，嗯，他们看起来确实挺快乐的，不是吗？我们的浴缸几年前坏了，乔，整个浴室都需要修理，需要彻底拆掉重新装修，这是我们一直没有完全抽出时间去弄的事情。但我们在夏天度假时用了一个非常棒的浴缸，我和我最小的孩子每天都会用那个浴缸，虽然在这个年纪我们不是一起洗的，但是每天都用。我当时就想，哦，我太喜欢泡澡了。我可能比起淋浴更喜欢泡澡。这真的让我觉得，是的，我们确实需要把这个浴室的情况弄好，因为我需要
my regular baths. Yeah, well, everybody's different. And they did a lot of different research that even listening to water, seeing any types of water. So you don't actually have to live near water as well. And I think that's the interesting thing. So there is almost like a primitive instinct built in with us that, you know, maybe it's because we know how important water is because we have to have it for life that we're primed almost to be attracted to water. So yeah, listening to water and seeing bodies of water. So that might be really helpful. for anybody that is really supporting people with mental health to think about some sort of bringing water into therapy as well. Yeah, that's so important, isn't it? And we've got the whole
定期泡澡。是的，好吧，每个人都是不同的。他们做了许多不同的研究，甚至只是听水声、看任何类型的水。所以你其实也不必非得住在水边。我认为这正是最有趣的地方。所以我们体内几乎内置了一种原始本能，你知道，也许是因为我们知道水有多么重要，因为我们生命离不开它，所以我们几乎天生就被水吸引。所以，是的，听水声和看水体。对于任何真正支持有心理健康问题的人来说，这可能也非常有用，可以考虑把某种水元素引入治疗中。是的，这太重要了，不是吗？我们有整套的
kind of Wim Hof cold water movement and stuff. But actually, it's just really lovely to be in water, to develop your own rituals around water. And I think, like you said, to be really mindful of thinking about how that water feels on your skin. And yeah, I find that I think very different thoughts. It helps me to think more clearly when I'm, when I'm relaxed and in water. Yeah, I love that. I love that idea, Joe. And, you know, you can develop your own sense. You know, can really uplevel the sensory, can't you? Think about your favorite bath oil sense or, yeah, like there's, you know, whether you, I always, this is a little spoil. lullet, every bath I've had probably for the last 10 or 15 years, I have listened to the
诸如维姆·霍夫（Wim Hof）冷水疗法之类的运动。但实际上，身处水中，围绕水培养你自己的仪式感，真的是一件非常美好的事情。而且我认为，就像你说的，要真正用心去体察水在皮肤上的感觉。是的，我发现我的思维方式会发生很大的变化。当我放松并置身于水中时，它能帮助我更清晰地思考。是的，我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢这个想法，乔。而且，你知道的，你可以培养自己的感受。你知道的，真的可以提升感官体验，对吧？想想你最喜欢的沐浴油气味，或者，是的，就像有，无论你是否——我总是，这是一个小剧透，差不多过去10到15年里我洗的每一个澡，我都一直在听
Rayla Montaigne Trouble album. I would declare that to be the perfect bath soundtrack, like every bath. So for me, I just love that ritualistic nature of that and just the thoughts that come. Yeah, I love it. But also, we're born from amniotic fluid, aren't we? We've We've been surrounded in water for the whole of our gestation. And I wonder if that's something about the power of water. I'm sure it is. And I think also just our nervous systems have an almost like social connection. So if we're building that ritual up and we know that feeling,
雷拉·蒙泰涅（Raya Yarbrough/Ray LaMontagne）的《Trouble》这张专辑。我会宣称这是完美的洗澡配乐，每一次洗澡都是如此。所以对我来说，我就是喜欢那种充满仪式感的本质以及随之而来的思绪。是的，我很喜欢！而且，我们也是从羊水中诞生的，不是吗？我们
even if we've had a bad day, again, just the music, the sound of the bath. Something inside, doesn't it, switches over and goes, oh, I know what this is. and it's just like oh yeah so i think there's nothing better at the end of the day to have a bath yourself if you feel like oh i really really need to or yeah if your baby is just um needing that time with you as well so i would always um suggest have a little think about introducing some water rituals together definitely yeah absolutely and thinking about i think it's thinking about making that shift with even bath times from, oh, I've got to do this or, you know, this is a thing we must do, to thinking about it as an activity, something to be enjoyed
在整个孕期都被水包围着。我想这其中一定有什么关于水的力量的秘密。我确信是的。而且我认为，我们的神经系统也几乎具备一种社交连接的功能。所以如果我们建立起这种仪式感，并且我们熟悉那种感觉，
and look forward to. And I really like the idea of maybe thinking about when you do that in the day when they're most receptive to that, rather than thinking, oh, God, we've got to do that at the end of every day or, you know, when maybe your resources are sapped, maybe the baby's resources are sapped as well it's it's you know respecting both of you really it is and i think also that we just underestimate the power of water and there's so many times when you know it's it's there and it's accessible it's free and it's natural and i think sometimes just because it's there we forget about it don't we but yeah definitely that i think you know thinking about it in water in in a different way, in a mindful way, is, yeah, different mind shift for people.
即使我们度过了糟糕的一天，再次听到音乐、洗澡的声音。内心深处的某种东西就会切换过来，然后心想，“哦，我知道这是什么。”然后就会觉得，“哦，是的。”所以我觉得在一天结束时，如果你觉得“我真的、真的很需要”，或者如果你的宝宝也需要和你在一起的时光，没有什么比自己泡个澡更好的了。所以我总是会建议，考虑一下共同引入一些水仪式，绝对是的。是的，绝对是，而且考虑到——我认为这是关于如何甚至把洗澡时间从“哦，我必须做这个”或者“你知道的，这是我们必须做的事情”这种心态转变过来，把它看作一项活动，一件值得享受的事情。
Yeah, and you've made water your whole career, certainly since you became a parent anyway. And I remember when we were in the pool together and that's probably the end of the lesson. And you were like, oh, I've got this dream to have my own pool one day. And then at the end of our sessions, I think you then opened your first pool. I think you've now got a couple of pools. and it really is, it's become your life's mission, hasn't it? Yeah, I mean, I was really fortunate that as a child, I always used to spend a lot of time in water with my dad
并且充满期待。我真的很喜欢这种想法，也许可以想想在一天中宝宝最能接受的时候去做，而不是去想，“天哪，我们必须在每天结束时做这件事，”或者，当你的精力耗尽时，也许宝宝的精力也耗尽了，这（实际上）是在尊重你们双方，确实如此。而且我也认为，我们只是低估了水力量，很多时候，你知道的，它就在那里，触手可及，它是免费的、天然的，而且我认为有时候正因为它就在那里，我们反而忽视了它，对吧？但是，是的，绝对地，我认为以一种不同的、正念的方式来看待水，对人们来说确实是一种不同的心态转变。
and I think that that built that almost foundation relationship. And then when I was made redundant on maternity leave, you know, and you're just like searching, you're thinking, oh, I don't know what to do. It just happens to land and I was taking my little boy, baby swim, and this is going back 22 years now. And I was, I was a little bit low at the time because I didn't have a lot of friends. I moved areas.
是的，你把水当成了你一整份职业，至少在你成为父母之后一直是这样。我记得当我们在泳池里一起上课，那大概是课程结束的时候。你说过，“哦，我有一个梦想，有一天能拥有我自己的泳池。”然后在那次课程结束后不久，我想你开办了自己的第一个泳池。我想你现在已经有好几个泳池了。这真的，已经成为你一生的使命了，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，我很幸运，小时候我总是花很多时间和爸爸一起在水里度过，
So it was almost that, as we've been talking about, that postnatal support group as well. So I really lent into my friends group through swimming. So it definitely had much more of that emotional attachment when I got made redundant with my daughter. It was almost like there just presenting. I was like, right, fine. So it was almost like a path. And when I was hiring pools, I just felt like, yeah, we could be doing this a little bit different.
并且我认为这建立了那种近乎基础的关系。然后当我在产假期间被裁员时，你知道，当你只是在寻找出路，心想，“哦，我不知道该做什么。”它就那样降临了。当时我正带着我的小男孩去上婴儿游泳课，这已经要追溯到22岁那年了。当时我的情绪有点低落，因为我没有很多朋友，我搬到了新的地方。
The environment needs to be different for babies, warmer, lots of different new facilities. And I wanted to create much more of a community connection. So it was really tough building our own pools. But yeah, I absolutely love our swim families and the community that we're building. And then through just introducing now out to others and more of like saying that the bath can be that first step to the pool and really helping and supporting others with that as well. Yeah, what I liked about your approach, Joe, was it was so respectful of the baby.
所以这几乎就像是我们一直在谈论的产后支持小组一样。所以我真的通过游泳融入了我的朋友圈。因此，当我女儿出生时再次面临裁员，它绝对带有了更多情感上的依附。这感觉就像是自然而然地出现了。我当时就想：“好吧，行。”所以这几乎就像是一条道路。当我租用泳池时，我只是觉得，“是的，我们可以把这件事做得稍微有点不同。”
We're not doing like, not chucking them in. We're not dunking them straight away. Like, we're not putting those funny little floaty things on their heads and letting them float off by themselves. Like, it was really empowering to, to respect the baby and to gently introduce a few splashes to their face of the water so that they could see that for themselves. And just to be baby led, you know, I think sometimes we did gently pull baby underwater, but only when they were, when we thought that that would be okay. And I hope I'm not remiss remembering that, Joe. I think that does happen at some points in the lessons. But it's empowering you to think about what's right for your baby, what's right for what's right for you and them on any given day.
婴儿需要的环境应该有所不同，要更温暖，有许多不同的新设施。而且我想要创造更多的社区连接。所以建立我们自己的泳池真的非常艰难。但是，是的，我非常热爱我们的游泳家庭以及我们正在建立的社区。然后通过向其他人介绍，并且更多地推广“浴缸可以作为通往泳池的第一步”，以此来真正帮助和支持其他人。是的，乔，我喜欢你的一点在于，你的方法对婴儿是如此尊重。
Like I just, I really loved, really loved your way. And I found it really empowering. actually as a first-time mum, just to think about how to do these things and to give me confidence. Yeah. And I think what's interesting over the 15 years, or particularly when you were swimming as well, things have changed. And we've become much more attuned. So as you said, you know, when we were teaching babies then, we were always very respectful. We gave them the queue. We thought they were ready. We look for those cues, those bright eyes leaning forward, and we allow them into the water. Now we're really, really tuned into sort of taking again, much more of a little bit more of a sort of just our step back. And rather than holding baby, we're really now allowing their very first underwater dip themselves. So baby swimming is really, really changing in the UK.
我们不是在“把他们扔进去”。我们不会马上把他们按到水里。我们不会把那些滑稽的小浮漂套在他们头上然后让他们自己漂走。真正赋能的一点是，去尊重婴儿，温和地在他们的脸上撩一点水，这样他们就能自己看到水。而且要以婴儿为主导，你知道，有时候我们确实会温柔地把婴儿带到水面下，但前提是我们认为他们已经准备好了。我希望我没有记错，乔。我认为在课程的某些阶段确实会发生这种情况。但这赋予了你力量去思考什么对你的宝宝是正确的，在任何特定的一天，什么对你和他们才是正确的。
Not so much around the world, but I think, you know, one of these things might sort of catch up. But yeah, we do have a lot of different practices worldwide and I'm a massive advocate. of child led baby swimming because well at the end of the day you want your children to be happier and safer and to for me be connected to the water rather than you know just building in any in built fears really yeah and i think one of the limiting factors can be the cost of baby swimming because you're having smaller groups and of course the very high overheads of running a pool or or hiring a pool, it's not easy. It's easy to kind of think about the companies as being, you know, mercenary.
就像我真的——我真的很喜欢你的方式。作为一个新手妈妈，它让我感到充满了力量，让我思考如何做好这些事情并赋予我信心。是的，而且我认为有趣的是，在过去的15年里，或者特别是在你当时也在游泳的时候，情况已经发生了变化。我们变得更加合拍了。正如你所说，你知道，那时我们教婴儿游泳时，总是非常尊重他们。我们会给他们一个信号，如果我们认为他们准备好了。我们会寻找那些信号，比如明亮的眼睛身体前倾，然后我们允许他们下水。现在我们真正、真正调整到——再次采取一种稍微退后一步的方式。我们不再是抱着婴儿，而是现在真正允许他们自己进行人生中的第一次水下潜水。所以英国的婴儿游泳正在发生巨大、巨大的变化。
Like, how can they dare charge us that much? But the overheads are really high, and it's not the same as having a whole big leisure center full of paying customers. And so it is going to be perhaps more expensive. I think, you know, you guys were the most expensive baby class I did, but I would say it was worth it. And what I learned from that and what I took from that with my son, I think it's, it was really, really important.
世界其他地方可能没那么大变化，但我认为，你知道，其中一些地方可能会迎头赶上。但是，是的，我们在世界各地确实有许多不同的做法，我是以儿童为主导的婴儿游泳的坚定倡导者，因为归根结底，你希望你的孩子更快乐、更安全，对你来说，是让他们与水建立联系，而不是（在他们心中）种下任何天生的恐惧。是的，我认为限制因素之一可能是婴儿游泳的费用，因为你需要较小的班级规模，当然运营泳池或租用泳池的管理成本非常高，这并不容易。人们很容易认为这些公司是唯利是图的，
Oh, thank you. I think it just works on all different levels, isn't it? It's a class for us. It's a class for baby. But I think also just long term, you know, we know that we're giving them the best start developmentally as well. You know, swimming has one of those magical ways of like just crossing all the brain domains, you know, the cognitive, the social, the speech and language.
心想：“怎么敢收我们这么多钱？”但运营成本真的很高，这和拥有一个挤满付费客户的大型休闲中心是不一样的。所以它可能确实更贵。我想，你知道，你们是我报过的最贵的婴儿班，但我会说这是物有所值的。我从中学到了什么，以及我和儿子一起从中收获了什么，我认为，这真的、真的非常重要。
It's just, it's all there. So I would say if parents were looking, for any class you know baby swimming pop it up there or if you can't go to classes then definitely definitely go yourself there shouldn't really be any barrier to you know go into water or having water at home really start there yeah and you've got new classes as well like bath time classes could you tell us about those yes thank you well just love really celebrating the fourth trimester and just slowing it all down and I do think that sometimes, you know, rushing to the pool isn't always baby led. I mean, talking about like the first baby sort of like two months
哦，谢谢你。我觉得它在不同的层面上都发挥了作用，不是吗？对我们来说这是一节课，对宝宝来说这是一节课。但我也认为，从长远来看，你知道，我们在发育上也给予了他们最好的起步。你知道，游泳有一种神奇的方式，能够跨越所有的大脑领域，比如认知、社交、言语和语言。
and the bath can be the perfect place and, you know, sometimes just being in that social environment. So if you can think of a little bit of like a nurturing touch baby massage mixed with baby swim, that's what we've created. It's really unique. It's called bath babies and it's a time where we're really celebrating together, really making sure babies are seen and heard, giving parents, really nice bath time tips, and it's really, really good fun as well. But for me, it's just making early water experience is special, but also it is making things much more accessible. Because I must admit, when I, or before I started bath babies,
它就在那里，全都在那儿。所以我想说，如果父母们在寻找任何课程，你知道，婴儿游泳绝对值得考虑，或者如果你不能去上课，那就绝对、绝对自己带孩子去，不应该有什么真正的阻碍去接触水或在家里玩水，从那里开始吧。是的，你还有新的课程，比如洗澡时间课程，你能跟我们讲讲吗？是的，谢谢你。我真的很喜欢庆祝第四孕期（产后头三个月），并把节奏慢下来。而且我的确认为有时候，急匆匆地去泳池并不总是以婴儿为主导。我是说，说到像前两个月左右的婴儿，
I didn't have an appreciation of how many people were, perhaps we're a bit fearful of going into water themselves or cultural differences or skin or healing from birth, anything really. I didn't have a huge appreciation. So bath babies is actually almost like bridging a gap as well, making early water really accessible. So I'm really super excited to bring that to my local community, but also to others as well, supporting others, setting up their own bath babies. Yeah, and before we hit record, we were talking about actually this is a really nice opportunity potentially for people who want to build more experience with clinically relevant populations to perhaps take this into their own hands and think actually
浴室可以是一个完美的地方，你知道，有时候仅仅是身处那种社交环境中。所以，如果你能想象把一种充满滋养触感的婴儿按摩与婴儿游泳结合起来，这就是我们所创造的。它是如此独特。它被称为“洗澡宝宝（Bath Babies）”，这是一个我们真正一起庆祝、确保婴儿被看见和听见、给父母提供非常棒的洗澡小贴士的时刻，而且它真的、真的非常有趣。但对我来说，这只是让早期的水上体验变得特别，同时也让事情变得更加平易近人。因为我必须承认，当我——或者在我开始“洗澡宝宝”之前，
maybe I could set up a little, you know, practice of teaching these bath classes to people so that I could work with postnatal populations and kind of parent and baby diet. I think it's potentially something that I would have been really really interested in earlier in my career for sure. Could you tell us a bit about how those kind of training the trainers courses would work, Joe? Yeah, sure. So I'm an aquatic tutor and the course has been accredited by SimSpar, which is, like I say, is like the offstead of aquatics in the UK, all the swim qualifications are accredited and off. inspire accredited bar babies. So that's really important, first of all, that people are getting approved and quality training. And secondly, I like to work with people in all sorts of different ways, whether it's online, face-to-face. But the idea is that at the end, when they're setting up
我并没有意识到有多少人，也许他们自己有点害怕下水，或者存在文化差异、皮肤问题、产后恢复等等。我之前并没有深刻的认识。所以“洗澡宝宝”实际上几乎就像是在搭建一座桥梁，让早期的水上体验变得非常容易获得。所以我真的超级兴奋能把它带到我的当地社区，同时也带给其他人，支持其他人建立他们自己的“洗澡宝宝”课程。是的，在我们按下录音键之前，我们还在谈论其实这是一个非常好的机会，潜在地适合那些想要积累更多与临床相关群体工作经验的人，他们也许可以把这一点抓在自己手里，心想，
their case studies, they can actually run and be really confident to run their own classes. So we are really appealing to anybody that is working with children, naught to five, and they want to set up classes. But it can be like, you know, supportive classes. It could be parents that have had really sensitive or babies that have had sensitive beginnings as well. You can go down a little more of a sort of a therapeutic way if that is your, you know, your foundation base. But essentially what we're doing is we're creating safe spaces. We're celebrating that fourth trimester and being together and then the water's there sort of like holding that space as well. And I like to say like water is can be our teacher as well. You know, go in with the flow. There are so many different
也许我可以建立一个小型的、你知道的，面向大众教授这些洗澡课程的业务，这样我就可以与产后人群以及父母与婴儿二元关系进行工作。我认为这绝对是我在职业生涯早期会非常、非常感兴趣的事情。乔，你能跟我们讲讲这些类似于“培训师培训”的课程是如何运作的吗？是的，当然。所以我是水上教育导师，这门课程已经获得了SimSpa的认证，就像我说的，它就像是英国水上运动的Ofsted（教育标准办公室），所有的游泳资格都经过认证，而“洗澡宝宝”也获得了SimSpa认证。所以首先，这一点非常重要，即人们能够获得批准和高质量的培训。其次，我喜欢以各种不同的方式与人们合作，无论是在线还是面对面的。但其理念是，在最后，当他们建立自己的案例研究时，他们实际上可以运营并非常有信心运营自己的课程。所以我们真的在吸引任何与0到5岁儿童合作并且想要开设课程的人。但这可以像是，你知道的，支持性课程。它也可以针对那些有过非常敏感经历的父母，或者有过敏感开端的婴儿。如果那是你的基础，你可以走稍微多一点治疗性质的路线。但本质上我们在做的是，我们正在创造安全空间。我们庆祝第四孕期并在一起，然后水就在那里，就像是在守护那个空间。我喜欢说，水也可以成为我们的老师。顺其自然。水实际上可以教给我们很多不同的信息，并把这些课程共同维系起来。是的，如果我当时在产后服务部门从事线下工作，我绝对会说，我认为我们当中至少需要有一个人接受过培训，以便能够对父母进行这种可爱的干预水平，从而支持这种亲密关系的建立。所以这也是另一条途径。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你的工作的信息，乔？如果人们想要线下的婴儿游泳，你的泳池在哪里？谢谢。
messages that the water can actually teach us and holding those classes together really. Yeah, I think if I was working in a postnatal service where I was doing in person work, I would absolutely be saying, I think at least one of us needs to be trained to be able to do this lovely level of intervention with parents to support that bonding. So that's another avenue. Where can people learn more about you and your work, Jo? And if people did want in-person baby swimming, where are your pools? Thank you.
所以我的基地在沃里克郡（Warwickshire）。我有两个泳池，一个在拉格比（Rugby），一个在利明顿温泉（Leamington Spa）。但我也会在网上做大量的工作。所以通过Acrosensory，这个项目被称为“洗澡宝宝”。我在亚马逊上有一本书，我把它定在最低价格，所以父母们很容易获得。Kindle版是2.99英镑，纸质版是3.99英镑。书名叫《洗澡宝宝：在水中建立美丽的亲密关系》。
So I'm based in Warwickshire. I've got two pools, one in rugby, one in Lemington Spa. but I do an awful lot of work online as well. So through aquasensory and the program is called Bath Babies. And I have a book on Amazon and what I did is I set it at the lowest price. So it's really accessible for parents. So it's 299 Kindle, 399 print. And it's called Bath Babies creating beautiful bonds in water.
它几乎总结了我们今天一直在谈论的内容，那种正念的方式，并且也给我们提供了一些实践。太棒了！非常感谢你抽出时间，也非常感谢你为婴儿及其照顾者之间正在发展的这种亲密关系和连接所做的一切。这真的太重要了。哦，谢谢你邀请我。不用谢。非常感谢我今天的嘉宾乔。对于我和大孩子在泳池里同她在一起的时光，我至今依然怀念不已。这一集对你来说感觉如何？我很想知道。如果你在YouTube上观看，请务必留下评论，无论你在哪里观看节目，请点赞并订阅。并且让我知道
And it pretty much sums up what we've been talking today, that mindful way and gives us some practices as well. Amazing. Thank you so much for your time and thank you so much for everything that you do for these developing bonds and relationships with babies and their caregivers. It's really important. Oh, thank you for having me. You're so welcome. Thank you so much to my guest, Joe, today. I still do think back very fondly on my time with her in the pool with my eldest child. How has this episode been for you? I would love to know. Please do drop a comment if watching on YouTube, please do like and subscribe wherever you're watching the show. And let me know what
未来你觉得哪些内容会有所帮助。如果你正在和新手父母合作，或者你自己就是一位新手父母，或者想要支持、你知道的，接触那些新手父母，我也强烈推荐我的一位同事写的一本书。书名叫《正念新手妈妈》（Mindful New Mum），作者是卡罗琳·博伊德（Caroline Boyd）博士。我觉得这是一本非常、非常可爱、有滋养的书，值得考虑如何在产后阶段支持母亲或如何支持你自己。所以，是的，除了婴儿游泳之外，这本书也得到了我的认可。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这本书成为你的指南。
content you would find helpful in future too. If you are working with new parents or you are a new parent yourself or want to support or, you know, reach out to someone who is, I also really recommend a book by one of my colleagues. It's called Mindful New Mum and it's by Dr. Caroline Boyd. It really is a lovely, lovely nourishing read, I would say, for thinking about how to support mothers or how to support yourself in the postnatal period. So, yeah, that gets my seal of approval as well as baby swimming. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide.
有了这个播客，这就是你通往资格认证的伴侣。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。嗨，我叫贝丝（Beth），是一名来自纽卡斯尔的心理健康从业者。我只想向《临床心理学家合集》一书的撰稿人表达由衷的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解大家在申请博士学位之前所经历的各种背景和经历。了解申请的潜在障碍以及我如何努力克服这些障碍真的非常有趣。我曾一度开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀，能否申请临床心理学博士学位，但这真的给了我所需要的信心，让我去尝试一下。所以非常、非常感谢你们。
With this podcast, that's your side to be on your way to be on. qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Mary and Trent. Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest
这集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。